it has served an economic interest to
have white people prefer to see
themselves as better than people of
color who may even be similarly situated
so that they can sort of divide the
working and middle class and this divide
and conquer strategy is older than the
nation it is one of the first sort of
things that the colonial elite did in
order to maintain
racial slavery and to convince the
masses of white people who were here in
servitude that they were somehow better
than african slaves and frankly get them
to defend
slavery
which was nonetheless
enslaving these white people out of a
job right
enslaved black people were
not slaver was not in the near-term
immediate economic interest of white
indentured servants in the pre-american
days and the colonial days
and yet
as a response to cross-racial uprisings
among
servants who were white black and
indigenous
the elite created a difference and said
hey white people side with your race
instead of your class
and that's what
conservative race mongers are doing
today and for the same goal to make sure
that the economic elite has the buy-in
of the mass of white people